president trumpets fond of calling out
the media on fake news but is he the one
giving them very real ammunition maybe
not intentionally I'll even give you the
benefit of the doubt mr. president say
maybe not deliberately but consistently
Wade you consistently so let me be clear
mr. president
how can you drain the swamp if you're
the one who keeps muddying the waters
you didn't know about that $130,000
payment to a porn star I think you did
said you knew nothing about how your
former lawyer Michael Cohen handle this
until acknowledging today you were the
guy behind the retainer payment that
took care of this you insists that money
from the campaign or campaign
contributions played no role in this
transaction of that your short thing is
not even 24 hours ago sir you couldn't
recall any of this and you seem very
sure now I'm not saying you're a liar
you're president you're busy I'm just
having a devil of a time figuring out
which news is fake let's just say your
own words on lots of stuff give me shall
I say lots of pause like the time you
said the Russians didn't interfere in
the 2016 election until a lot of
Republicans had to remind you they did
came back months later and you said well
I never said that Russia didn't meddle
in the election when in fact you had a
lot now none of this makes me a never
Trump er just always confused like when
you claim your tax plan was the biggest
in US history when it wasn't or that the
building is signed to make it all happen
would cost you a fortune when it turns
out it is going to help make you a
bigger fortune or that your job approval
novels really aren't that bad relative
to other presidents at this stage when
they're actually worse than most
presidents at this stage that can change
but what's weird is this pattern does
not like the times that you said rumors
of Rex Tillerson departure at the State
Department were false until they weren't
or that your former chief of staff
Reince Priebus wasn't going anywhere
until he was or your economic adviser
Gary Cohen was doing
great job until he wasn't when you
absolutely love Steve Bannon until you
didn't swore by Jeff Sessions that you
started swearing at Jeff Sessions had
your legal team locked in place until
then wasn't denied reports you were ever
thinking about firing Robert Muller even
as you now threatened getting involved
at the Justice Department now none of
this makes you evil but I'm sure you can
understand why even your friends say
these inconsistencies don't make you
look good or do anything to help advance
your policies many of which are very
good or the prospects for peace with
North Korea that is remarkably good all
this stuff you keep blurting out
remarkably bad and remarkably bad timing
it is not that these exaggerations and
omissions and Mis statements are now and
then more like now and then something
else always something else like the time
you claim you sign more bills than any
president ever neglecting to mention the
other four presidents FDR Truman Carter
and Clinton who will sign more or brag
about the national debt going down by 12
million dollars after your first month
in office even though it's sorted by
nearly a trillion bucks now that you're
15 months in office but it's not what
you are omitting mr. president it is
what you keep stating and never
correcting
like when you said there was a serious
voter fraud in New Hampshire and there
was it said the same about repeated
claims of voter fraud in Virginia and
there weren't or that millions of
illegals voted in the last election but
they didn't well the time you talked up
your massive landslide in the electoral
college even though three out of four
presidents before you had bigger
electoral vote landslides in their
elections again none of this makes what
you say fake just calling out the press
for being so a bit of a stretch you are
right to say some of them are out to get
you but often times they're using your
own words to bash you your base probably
might not care but you should I guess
you're too busy draining the swamp to
ever stop and smell the stink you're
creating that's your doing
that's your stink mr. president
that's your swamp good night